the health problems of your child are
obviously horrific in themselves I pray
to God I never have to go through
anything like that I it's it's greatest
fear any parent has and then on top of
that your government will not permit you
to treat your child or keep your child
alive and on top of that the UK
government will not
allow the government of Italy which gave
your child citizenship will not allow
the Pope will not allow the Vicor of
Christ on Earth to help treat your child
they simply want to kill your baby tell
us what's what's happening we're just
absolutely disgusted um I'm embarrassed
to be British at a minute we've got
another country offering to pay for the
treatment and they're blocking her from
going to Italy they're blocking her to
for coming home to get
exbition they're just being it's just so
cruel and inhumane we just don't
understand